[Music]
in disgusting human news submitted by
lickety split the lapd is investigating
a youtuber who appeared to be
appeared to abuse her dog in a viral
video oh this [ __ ]
[ __ ] this [ __ ] what this [ __ ] is a
[ __ ]
really everyone sent me this [ __ ] yeah i
mean [ __ ]
off was like how dare you [ __ ] [ __ ]
i will
show you so this is brooke
she looks is she from where's she from
it's from canada from i don't she looks
like
this is brook's head shot jesus but i do
know that she lives in
l.a right because lapd are involved
exactly lapd are involved
so uh recently she uploaded a video to
her channel which has more than 330 000
subscribers
um and her thing was about like her
pranking her dog and apparently she
uploads a lot of videos with her
doberman
and she even puts it on the title and
stuff so i like doberman dog
fur views a lot so this is the video
that she accidentally uploaded
unedited so people oh
i know she accidentally so she went to
cut down i see this
oh she wanted to cut this stuff out so
she ended up uploading it i don't know
how long it was
up for but people obviously saw this and
recorded it and thank god
and then so she took that initial video
down and then she uploaded an edited
more polished version but as of now like
she took that one down as well because
she's been receiving
an insane amount of good she deserves
look at this [ __ ]
watch this [ __ ] it makes you want to be
header really
figuratively speaking not literally okay
because we're in l.a and i don't want to
get in trouble for any type of things
that
it's this comedy show okay let's go all
right
what's up everyone it's your girl brooke
here today for this video i wanted to
prank my dog
she's over there i put plastic wrap on
the door i'm gonna have him
run out we're just gonna see what he
does i don't know
oh damn well as you can tell
oh look at this
i hate her she spit on her dog that was
like
what oh i hate her reading on the dog
was like something
or whatever wow i hate her i hate her we
love you
and he learns and he's like i love you i
hate her
we love you
[ __ ] this [ __ ] take your dog take the
dogs take
that's what i'm saying who spits on the
[ __ ] dog well spitting on the dog is
like the least
thing that perfect you could smack the
dog but don't spit on the dog nominees
that's your own [ __ ] and [ __ ] i mean
yeah that's the least abusive thing but
the fact that she even
gets there yeah there's nothing through
her dog like what the [ __ ] is wrong
i hate her i [ __ ] spit like just
hitting the dog on the head like that
when he's just
and it's just like and he's like running
to you like what's so happy he's just a
very energetic dog
very happy too she's a [ __ ] train
that yeah she doesn't know how to train
the dog you know how to work with his
energy she's a [ __ ] idiot
yeah she gets frustrated and yeah well
cause she wants what she wants and she
wants it and she's using this dog for
[ __ ]
views and she's she doesn't walk him she
doesn't take care of him i'm not making
all this [ __ ] up but i [ __ ] hate her
i bet you she doesn't man like the level
of
energy that he has high and he needs to
like let his wiggles out you know
i know so this [ __ ]
she posted this really long
does it mean [ __ ] for sure but it's like
on the note
i [ __ ] hate her i'm with you 100 oh i
hate her i don't give a [ __ ]
what she says what she's apologizing for
the image already said more than what
she can ever feel like eloquently
19. geo's calling out [ __ ] what's her
name
to a boxing yeah i will [ __ ] i will
beat her ass and spit on her face
yeah i'm gonna push her with both hands
and we say no no y'all gonna be sick sit
you [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
i'm gonna check what are you gonna do
he's so into it spit on me the thing
so this is the thing that she posted on
twitter [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's four screenshots of her notes
her note thing that's like full on like
just her
rambling pretty much um i hate her
all that she's saying here is pretty
much saying
like boiling it down she's saying you
know that day
i was having a really bad day makes no
[ __ ] right well that actually changes
things a little bit
oh i've had a bad day too and i beat my
animals
all the time i get it girl i didn't know
that she doesn't normally spit but this
one was like she hits them all the time
but
the spitting is like she had just been
in traffic for two hours guys
yeah yeah she said that um
oh i spit on my friends all the time
when i'm pissed well about the spitting
she said that she did not spit on her
dog and she knows it looks like she did
but she did not
no one gives it oh she's a [ __ ] dude
i heard that
exactly the thing in her throat like i
said that's the least offensive thing
she did
like retracted like you could hear her
and then
afterwards you could see something like
her lip kind of like wiping the [ __ ]
spit like her
[ __ ] you spit on your dog but it
doesn't it's liar dude i had a friend
who used to spit in their dog's mouth
and the dog would catch it
ew and like it so that's different you
have some weird friends oh [ __ ] where
your friends
they weren't white my friend used to
jack off his dog
no they weren't eating it's definitely
not amazing
spanish filipino filipino
oh my god that's the [ __ ] first time
no one ever heard you dude
he said i used to have a friend that
would jack off their dog
no nobody gave a [ __ ]
then he thought someone finally heard
because he goes
and then you said spanish and he said
filipino but still no one gave a [ __ ]
i only heard steve i didn't even know i
didn't even hear joe what's this wait
who would you dropped off your dog
were they spanish well kalila too but
there's another person and then when
kalia kalila told the story i was like
oh my god filipinos love jacking off
their dogs
wow the first time you weren't hurt
it was worth hearing though yeah i will
say
oh [ __ ] i hate this [ __ ] back to the
apology thing so then she
is saying that she did not spit on her
dog she said that and then the rest of
her rambling is her saying how she's
been trying to train her dog that's not
how you turn it off pretty much
what to me and how i would summarize
she's caesar milan is that she's
just she is just coming up with any
excuse she can
to get away from this and she's saying
that it's the dog's fault for not being
trained
but what the [ __ ] like you're the one
that [ __ ] needs training you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah tell her
guys i'm a professional trainer and i
can tell you that
my dog [ __ ] sucks because they're not
trained
and then she also has to point out that
it's very expensive training
[ __ ] you suck a dick you stupid [ __ ]
wait her training is very expensive like
the training that for her can i hear
some of what she has said
i hate her well the training thing i
hate her please look me up
dm me i want to meet you because i
[ __ ] hate you
she wants to shake your hand [ __ ] [ __ ]
we're in l.a too underscore
antoinette send me a damn to the fans
hit her up tyler to hit me up
i want to see his fight please see this
why would she accept the flags
she defending dog abuse she's like i'm
sticking up for all dog abuse people
like what's her angle on it man exactly
i'm purposely calling her a [ __ ] so
that she can like try to defend her
honor that she's not a [ __ ]
so if she wins dog abuse is cool and
she's not a [ __ ]
that would suck if she wins right i
didn't think about this what are you
thinking i just thought it was
sad that she told her dog to come and
she probably didn't want her dog to
she wanted her dog to probably run
through it instead of jump and so she
wouldn't hit him
and she probably refilmed that again so
that he could run through it oh
i don't know i was like oh like i don't
know i just yeah right i like
uh what kind of videos does she have a
lot with her dog in it
a lot oh people are like this is
disgusting and that's why lapd
like they're looking into this because
they're called the police
that they this dog is not enduring oh
for sure it is for sure
it [ __ ] is like this dog needs to be
taken away they always have to say
allegedly all this [ __ ]
legally just for them yeah but you
wanted me to read a part so i'll read
the part about the training thing so she
says my family and i
are in the process of getting him
training the training that i have been
looking at for him is very expensive
because oh that's what you meant
one-on-one with a trainer ever since he
was attacked
at the dog park he isn't okay with being
around other dogs he sticks to me like
velcro if he is in the presence of
another dog even a little chihuahua i
just can't see him getting
what he needs from a group training
environment that being said i know i
personally can learn more effective
techniques to get his energy out and
keep him
disciplined as well but she's saying
that like as a dog mom
she had to oh because um she said that
this dog
weighs 75 pounds so when he jumped on
her that
she had to show him that that behavior
is unacceptable
and that's why she snapped at him well
dude also she didn't mention
it's like who attacked him at the dog
park she's like well i did yeah
was there any people like saying like
what you should do when a dog jumps up
or something like i don't
yeah you smack them no you don't smack
them well you do it with love
you push them like yeah you you grab the
head and you push
them down and then you kiss it after
people don't know
right i feel like i feel like there are
a lot of dogs that are being mistreated
and people just would
smack i feel like that's true right so
you know what you're saying when the dog
no you punch them in the stomach not on
the head that's right
that's tougher are you asking what
you're supposed to do is that weird
yeah for some people because i feel like
some energy wouldn't even know for real
what are you supposed to do
no you just you just assert the
dominance and not with physical
force you can use your body yeah and
then
a little a little but you don't do it
out of anger
like she's doing it out of frustration
and anger had your dogs in training so
what do they teach you in training well
it takes a lot of time right like like
so you have to spend a lot of time with
your doggy
and what we learned is more about the
repetition
of them understand and communicating
with your energy and using your body
as a as like a wall in a position so
like let's say if they get too
too like jumpy right you're supposed to
kind of tower over them so they can't
really jump
and then like keep your hands like out
or whatever
so they don't always try to rely on the
same thing because that's conditioning
they try to get to your face because
they want to kiss you or do
do other [ __ ] like that um and then
another one would be like if you're
walking with with them every day
and they get used to you just leading
then after a while they start listening
to you more too
so you're supposed to lead when you
watch them is that what you're saying
no no yeah so there's walking techniques
where like they they're they're like
doing what you call like a heel or like
they're walking close to not pulling
all these things so then the more time
you spend with them and you're leading
them around and you're kind of like
they're just following you and they feel
safe following you then they also listen
to you more too
so it's not just at the moment where you
just like stop or whatever
uh a lot of that stuff just doesn't work
because it's in the moment
you just got to spend multiple hours
training repertoire over and over and
over one
cure it's like it's it's over a long
period of time
dude when i had a dog my thing my thing
was always no that's bad and then their
face crinkles up like yeah they don't
even know
it's so sad that they let you down yeah
the ears go away oh
what i learned most well i don't there's
different training techniques right but
then like
they're really receptive to human energy
and like
your tone of voice and things like that
so if you stay calm or like if you
chill the energy out they tend to chill
out too but also you have to know the
age of your dog
so if it's like that dog's probably like
a little bit like a younger man
yeah younger man yeah like a juvenile or
whatever
like like lotta a lot of [ __ ] energy
right like they have to
run like a [ __ ] or else they
they're just like humans where you get
cabin fever and then you get all pent up
and you go crazy
the breed the age all of that there were
people commenting that are her viewers
saying like you know what i've i've seen
the way you
treat your dog for a long time and i
just assume that because you keep
mentioning that you're getting training
for your dog but they were saying like
you don't know how to treat this dog and
that breed
she doesn't know at all you could tell
like that dog is just
loose and she's clearly frustrated yeah
yeah
she doesn't know how to how to have a
dog at all i'm not in this
on a positive note yeah was a story
recently in the news that i saw
where it was about a kid who used to
sneak into his neighbor's garage
to to hang out with their dog to pet
their dogs
and you could see the video of this dog
and it's just in the garage
it's through a security cam and it's
just chilling and then all of a sudden
the tail starts going crazy
because this kid comes in and he sneaks
a hug and then he [ __ ] runs away
and they caught him on security cameras
doing the [ __ ] did they arrest him
that's right they busted his ass and
they put him in the gas chamber he's
dead now thank god no
that was a happy note the happy hour not
happy who was in the gas gym the
daughter the kid the kid
yeah but they buried the dog with the
kids okay cool yeah sounds kind of nice
foreign